[Applaus]
[Musik]
schnallt euch an wenn wir befinden uns
mitten in der grössten energiepreis
krise der letzten 50 jahre millionen von
menschen in europa machen sich sorgen
dass erste blick aus kommt oder dass sie
diesen winter ein vermögen für strom und
gas werden zahlen müssen in einigen
ländern hat sich der gast reist
vervielfacht aber das ist noch nicht das
schlimmste in mitteleuropa machen sich
die menschen das erste mal seit dem ende
des zweiten weltkriegs wieder säure dass
in diesem winter schlicht und einfach
nichts zum heißen haben werden und die
deutsche regierung will in dieser
situation auch noch kernkraftwerke
abschalten nun ja trotz dessen stürzen
sich die deutschen voller panik zb auch
auf elektroheizungen amazon deutschland
gibt bereits monate lange wartelisten
für den versand von elektrischen
heizkörper heraus heizkörper sind also
das toilettenpapier des jahres 2022
nimmt das hamstern denn nie ein ende
einige werden auch denken dass dies
eigentlich nichts neues system herbst
2021 gab es schon mal eine erdgas krise
als die preise ebenfalls in die höhe
geschossen sind damals kamen zwei
phänomene zusammen jahrelange des
investitionen in fossile brennstoffe und
ein anstieg der nachfrage nach gas die
preise schossen also in die höhe
im gegensatz zu vorher haben wir jetzt
aber krieg in europa und russland setzt
die drosselung seiner lieferungen an
erdgas auch als waffe ein aber auch
letztes wäre im grunde ja nichts neues
schließlich treibt putin seine
psychospielchen mit den gaslieferungen
schon seit jahrzehnten der unterschied
ist eben nur dass sich seine opfer
diesmal mitten in der eu befinden und
dagegen schon mal die nerven blank wenn
man plötzlich selbst von der kälte
bedroht wird nicht nur ein paar nachbarn
irgendwo im osten mit anderen worten
jeder ist sich nun mal selbst am
nächsten dabei war diese krise alles
andere als vorhersehbar und sie ist auch
nicht lokal oder gar regional sie ist
wirklich global ja liebe zuschauer sie
betritt sogar bereits so weit entfernte
länder wie pakistan
warum da die am ende dieses videos genau
verstehen dieses video wird wieder etwas
besonderes denn wir haben uns
vorgenommen wirklich alle zur verfügung
stehenden relevanten informationen zur
lage zusammen zu tragen und sie suche
euch aufzubereiten dass sie am ende
genau verstehen werdet die diese aus den
fugen geratenen energiemarkt nun
eigentlich funktioniert was sich hinter
den kulissen abspielt und auch was alles
dadurch auf uns zukommt welche werde
euch in diesem video einen haufen
zahlenmaterial um die ohren hauen müssen
was aber nun mal notwendig ist um die
wahren zusammenhänge zu verstehen und
wirklich fundiert argumentieren zu
können aber keine angst ich werde
natürlich versuchen alles sehr
verständlich zu halten und euch am ende
die drei wahrscheinlichsten szenarien
für diesen winter vorstellen und ja das
letzte szenario ist undeutlich
besorgniserregend allerdings ist die
lage auch nicht hoffnungslos außer frage
steht natürlich das wir vor einem der
unsichersten winter stehen die wir je
erlebt haben die gaskrise könnte alle
möglichen folgen haben folgen die so
verrückt sind wie diese
könnte es ein bier krise gebe technische
brauereien könnten durch gas mangel in
die knie gezwungen werden okay das wäre
dann auch für mich oder eine ganze reihe
my name is earl dritte kollegen ein
wörtliches schreckensszenario aber spaß
beiseite das thema erdgas da dermaßen
wichtig dass wir den nächsten wochen
eine ganze reihe von videos darüber
veröffentlichen werden in denen wir euch
alle wichtigen hintergründe ursachen und
lösungen der krise vorstellen werden
vergesst also bitte nicht das abo
unbedingt auch mit glöckchen denn ohne
glöckchen nimmt ist der youtube
algorithmus sowieso nicht ernst die
fragen die beim heutigen video klären
wollen lauten könnte europa in diesem
winter wirklich das erdgas ausgehen und
wie sieht konkreten zahlen aus die
hinter dieser krise stemmen wie wird
sich das alles auf andere länder aus um
welches zentrale machtspiel geht es bei
der ganzen geschichte und was kann
europa eigentlich tun um eine apokalypse
zu vermeiden also lasst uns keine
tabletten und gleich loslegen
russland das gas abdrehen
russland wirklich alle gaslieferungen
nach europa stoppen die antwort auf
diese frage lautet nein aber das heißt
es ist so gut wie undenkbar dass
russland jemals die gaslieferung zu 100%
unterbrechen würde und das schon aus
technischen gründen allerdings gibt es
dabei eine sehr große ausnahme stellen
wir uns aber zunächst einmal eine andere
frage wofür wird erdgas eigentlich
verwendet nur vor allem in vier
einsatzgebieten der stromerzeugung der
wärmeerzeugung für bestimmte
industriezweige der beheizung von
haushalten und als vorprodukt in der
chemischen industrie
um euch eine vorstellung zu geben gas
macht etwa 21 prozent des energiemixes
der gesamten europäischen union aus
allerdings haben nicht alle länder den
gleichen energie nächsten finden zb
macht das 0 7 prozent des energiemixes
aus der rest energie stammt aus
erneuerbaren quellen und kernreaktoren
in ländern wie polen und tschechien und
sind ist etwas 17 prozent aus gas die
tschechen setzen dabei vor allem auf
atomstrom tendenz steigend die polen auf
kohle ihr war die tendenz aber er fällt
so oder in deutschland werden dagegen
fast 26 prozent energie aus erdgas
erzeugt
[Musik]
und ihr fragt euch vielleicht warum so
viel nur weil man in deutschland
unbedingt alle atomreaktoren und
kohlekraftwerk abstellen wollte und zwar
fast gleichzeitig und sie
schnellstmöglich durch erneuerbare
energiequellen zu ersetzen
und was für viele laien erst mal nach
einer duften idee klingt entpuppt sich
beim näheren hinsehen als gigantische
mogelpackung und gefährliche illusion
zugleich denn zunächst einmal auf den
ersten blick sind die deutschen zahlen
recht beeindruckend wenn man nur die
ganz jahresbilanz betrachtet so haben
die deutschen in den vergangenen zwölf
jahren die stromerzeugung aus kohle und
43 auf 30 prozent reduziert man die aus
kernkraft und 22 auf 12 prozent
insgesamt also eine reduktion von 23%
punkten aus diesen beiden quellen dafür
wurden die anteil der erneuerbaren von
17 auf 42 prozent erhöht und das ist ein
plus von 25 prozent ziemlich
beeindruckend nicht wahr bliebe es bei
dieser reinen betrachtung müsste man den
deutschen als umwelt liegender mensch
eigentlich auf die schulter klopfen das
problem dabei die gesamtsumme für ein
ganzes jahr ist ziemlich irrelevant wenn
man gerade in einer windstillen nacht
seinen tee kochen oder warm duschen
möchte an vielen tagen im jahr schaffen
es wind und sonnenkraftwerke gerade mal
zehn prozent des national bedarf zu
decken und an einigen besonders gürtel
und windstillen noch nicht mal drei
prozent wie ihr seht entsteht genau dann
eine gewaltige lücke fast 40 prozent des
strombedarfs sie irgendwie abgefangen
werden muss denn strom muss genau in dem
moment erzeugt werden indem er gehe und
verbraucht wird scott des zuges
vorstädten blackout oder aber die
energie muss irgendwie gespeichert und
dann wieder abgerufen werden können und
das mit dem speichern ist ein gewaltiges
problem denn deutschland verbraucht pro
tag im schnitt 1 4 terawattstunden strom
verfügt jedoch auch nach vielen jahren
forcierten ausbaus nur über
speicherkapazitäten von
0,04 terawattstunden dh das land könnte
es bei voller ladung und entladung aller
energiespeicher gerade mal im mittel 40
minuten überbrücken wenn mal die sonne
nicht scheint und der wind nicht weht
aber das ist noch nicht alles die
täglichen 1 4 terawattstunden
entsprechen ja einer leistung von circa
58 gigawatt wenn diese gleichmäßig über
den ganzen tag hinweg verbraucht würde
aber genau das ist ja naturgemäß nicht
der fall schon gar nicht in einer
industrie nation genauso wie die
nachfrage zwischen einzelnen tagen und
saisonal schwankt schlägt sie auch
innerhalb eines einzigen tages gewaltig
nach oben und unten aus während nachts
manchmal nur 40 gigawatt leistung
benötigt werden können es tagsüber schon
mal über 75 gigawatt sein dass das dann
einfach mal auf die schnelle doppelt so
viel strom erzeugt werden muss was mit
hilfe von wind und sonnenkraft leider
nicht geht wofür ist aber eben
konventionelle kraftwerke gibt die eine
kombination aus grund- mittel- und
spitzenlast
energieerzeugung ermöglichen und da die
deutsche regierung entschieden hat dass
diese rolle vor allem gaskraftwerke
übernehmen sollen ja übernehmen müssen
da ja die atom und kohlekraftwerke dicht
gemacht werden ist in deutschland ein
gewisses cluster risiko entstanden das
heißt die kumulative häufung von
ausfallrisiken und wodurch die
energetische risikotragfähigkeit der
ganzen volkswirtschaft erheblich
geschwächt wurde die deutschen
regierungen der vergangenen jahrzehnte
haben also ganz eindeutig eine
mangelhafte risikodiversifizierung
betrieben mit dem verzicht auf eine
streuung der einzelrisiken durch einen
breiten und trat gegen energiemix die
deutsche politik und wirtschaft ganz
bewusst eine sehr riskante wette zu
gunsten eines mannes ein wladimir putin
es war angela merkel die diese
hochriskante wette federführend
abgeschlossen hat über ihren vorgänger
und putins wichtigsten buchmacher und
diele gerhard schröder und am 24 februar
2022 haben die deutschen diese
politische wette haushoch verloren die
schonungslose aufarbeitung dieser ganzen
geschichte wie deutschland systematisch
in die sucht nach russischem gas
getrieben wurde wenn wir euch bald in
einem separaten video präsentieren also
wie gesagt glöckchen nicht vergessen es
wird sich lohnen
[Musik]
aber wartet einen moment denn selbst all
das was wir bisher aufgezählt haben ist
nur ein teil des problems unabhängig vom
energiemix eines jeden landes gibt es
bestimmte bereiche in denen erdgas
unersetzlich ist zb können hochöfen in
stahlwerken nur mit erdgas befeuert
werden es gibt eine menge
industriebetriebe die für ihre
prozesswärme ford auf erdgas gesetzt
haben und nicht nur das 40 prozent der
heizungsanlagen in ganz europa werden
mit erdgas betrieben und wer nicht das
ganze jahr 2020 zwanzig jahren der höhle
gelebt hat weiß bereits dass der
großteil des gases das wenn europa
verbrauchen aus russland kommt oft
einfach mal einen blick auf diese karte
insgesamt macht russisches gas 40
prozent des gesamten gasverbrauchs in
europa aus es gibt länder die weniger
abhängig sind die spanier und italiener
zum beispiel werden in diesem winter
viel mehr für gas bezahlen aber sie
werden gas farben und warum weil
praktisch nichts davon aus russland
kommt darüber inwieweit übrigens die
überaus robuste gas infrastruktur
spaniens eine rettung für den rest
europas darstellen könnte werden wir in
einem separaten video sprechen ihr dürft
also schon mal gespannt sein es gibt
aber leider auch länder deren gas
infrastruktur heute nicht mehr so gesund
aussieht und die fast 100 prozent ihres
gases aus russland bezogen haben aber
von allen ländern die probleme haben ist
deutschland der spitzenreiter es ist
nicht nur besonders abhängig vom gas es
ist auch zu sehr vom russischen gas
abhängig eine fatale kombination an
dieser stelle sollten wir aber auch den
besonderen fall polen erwähnen polen ist
eines der wenigen länder in europa wie
das problem der abhängigkeit von
russischem gas ernst genommen und
zusammen mit norwegen eine pipeline
gebaut haben bevor es zu spät war
dadurch dass ich jetzt viel besser auf
die krise vorbereitet aber darüber
werden wir später sprechen
[Musik]
die wahrheit ist wenn putin das gas
abdreht haben deutschland und viele
andere länder ein problem die frage ist
allerdings ob es wirklich in seinem
interesse ist das zu tun nun die antwort
lautet dass es das theoretische nicht
ist und dabei geht es nicht nur darum
dass die energie experte mehr als 60
prozent der russischen staatseinnahmen
ausmachen und hieran zu rütteln sehr
gefährlich fürs überleben der russischen
regierung sein könnte klar bei den
aktuellen preisen den gashahn zuzudrehen
würde russland dutzende von milliarden
dollar kosten und gleichzeitig die pläne
der betroffenen länder beschleunigen in
zukunft keine nennenswerten lieferungen
aus diesem land mehr zu erhalten
europa ist schließlich mit abstand der
beste kunde russlands aber das ist noch
nicht alles klar geld regiert die welt
aber in diesem fall gibt es noch zwei
andere gründe die sogar noch wichtiger
sind als der schnöde mammon der eine
sind einfach die technischen realitäten
der infrastruktur die gigantischen
förderanlagen des sibirischen gasfeldern
müssen weiter in betrieb bleiben denn
würden sie erst einmal stillgelegt ist
eine wiederaufnahme der förderung extrem
aufwendig und kostspielig deswegen wird
gas das nicht sofort abtransportiert und
verkauft werden kann oft einfach
abgefackelt es in die atmosphäre
entweichen zu lassen wäre übrigens noch
umweltschädlicher und russland kann
seine kundschaft nicht einfach von heute
auf morgen wechseln die gasfelder sind
durch gigantische pipelines mit europa
verbunden die schon zu sowjetzeiten
gebaut wurden und deren kapazität muss
noch nicht einfach so irgendwo
replizieren kann schon gar nicht wenn es
einen haken technologie embargo
ausgesetzt ist
[Musik]
die produktion vor augen zu führen über
die wir hier reden im jahr 2021 in china
gerade mal zehn milliarden kubikmeter
gas aus russland über die neue
sibirische gaspipeline mittlerweile hat
russland ihre jährliche kapazität zwar
auf 16 5 milliarden kubikmeter
verdreifacht und will die gesamt
lieferkapazität nach china mit hilfe
einer neuen pipeline bis zum jahr 2025
nochmals auf 38 milliarden kubikmeter
erhöhen und wenn man dies jedoch mit den
liefermengen europa in bezug setzt wirkt
es wie ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
denn europa kauft er den russen bisher
jährlich zwischen 150 und 200 milliarden
kubikmeter gas ab das ist mehr als
fünfmal so viel wie die menge die russen
nach 2025 china zu liefern oft und das
nur wenn alles gut geht dass vor allem
wenn die chinesen auch mitspielen putin
bleibt also schlicht und ergreifend
keine zeit um verbindungen zu anderen
ländern wie china oder indien aufzubauen
schon gar nicht wenn man den aktuellen
kriegsverlauf in der ukraine
berücksichtigt die russen können ihr gas
auch nicht per schiff loswerden dass ich
hier fast alle ihre gaststätte an der
aktiven küste befinden tja viel glück
dabei mit einem lng tanker mitten im
winter durch den aktiven ota zu
schippern den ausbau von eisfreien lng
terminals und pipelines um diese zu
versorgung hatten nämlich die ganzen
jahre über sowieso verpennt das
kronjuwel der nördlichen sehr odt
gigantische durch ein französisch
japanisches konsortium errichtete und 27
milliarden dollar teure anlage ja mal
lng hat zwar eine jährliche
verflüssigung und verschloss kapazität
von 320 milliarden kubikmetern gas was
41 prozent der jährlichen kapazität der
nord stream-pipeline entspricht aber sie
befindet sich in einer alles andere als
optimalen geografischen lage für den
export nach asien das terminal auf der
russischen halbinsel wurde nämlich mit
der absicht gebaut das flugs lng
terminal im belgischen zeebrügge zu
versorgen in der absolute showstopper
ist jedoch die tatsache dass die neue
parks seven lies kreis lng tankerflotte
die russland gekauft hat um seine
energie durch das dicke eis von ja mal
aus zu transportieren in puncto wartung
und ersatzteile vollkommen auf
europäische unternehmen angewiesen ist
die ja mal lng zwei flotten bestehen aus
ascot schiffen und a sie trotz dieser
größe werden nur in finnland hergestellt
und 100 von tonnen gas in einem
technisch hochkomplexen spezial
kühlschiff ohne ordnungsgemäße wartung
durch die arktische see zu
transportieren könnte dann schon ein
spektakel werben an dass ich noch nicht
mal chinesische versicherungsfirmen
herantrauen dürften es gibt jedoch noch
einen letzten grund über den man einfach
nicht oft genug reden kann in auf diesem
grund die meisten missverständnisse wenn
es darum geht zu verstehen wie russland
tickt nun wie man mit diesem land
umgehen muss ob politisch oder
wirtschaftlich die meisten menschen und
dazu zählen auch politiker journalisten
oder manager erhalten gazprom noch immer
für ein gewöhnliches
wirtschaftsunternehmen es einfach nur
seine gewinne maximieren will und sich
entsprechend rational verhält stichwort
homo oeconomicus aber nichts könnte von
der realität weiter entfernt sein bei
gazprom rosneft und all den anderen
russischen rohstoffunternehmen gibt es
nur am rande um wirtschaft und geld
verdienen klar die milliarden werden
gerne mitgenommen an die amigos verteilt
und im staatshaushalt gebraucht aber in
wahrheit handelt es sich bei diesen
organisationen um die ökonomischen
wochen des kreml ihr ziel ist nicht die
gewinnmaximierung sondern die
durchsetzung der imperialistischen
nationalistischen agenda der putin ist
an allen schaltstellen dieser konzerne
sitzen anstelle erfahrener
wirtschaftsmanager von putin
handverlesene geheimdienstleute die rein
gar nichts von betriebsführung verstehen
dafür aber sehr viel von politik und
davon niemand machtstrukturen
kontrolliert und zwar sowohl in russland
als auch die in den zu beeinflussenden
ländern nach der russische imperialen
ideologie gibt es nämlich keine
souveränen staaten wie polen oder
deutschland oder die ukraine es gibt nur
großmächte die russland und die usa und
was all starten die großmächte können
mit ihren vasallen dabei machen was sie
wollen wenn diese spuren hat ihnen die
großmacht christ horses to falls nicht
wird sie einfach mal deren
volkswirtschaft ab es geht also schlicht
und einfach um erpressung politischer
entscheidungen früher waren die opfer
dieser politik zb belarus oder eben die
ukraine und heute ist es die größte
wirtschaftsnation europas deutschland
putin hat deutschland einfach zu sein
fit gemacht und man sieht daran
sein selbstvertrauen in die eigene macht
als erpresser in all den jahren steigern
konnte und manche denken erst jetzt zwar
eigentlich in seinem wahren element als
ultimativer gambler denn an dieser
bisher größten erpressung seines lebens
wird es sich als wirklich skrupelloser
bondrucker messen lassen müssen das
problem jedes abwassers ist jedoch dass
man niemanden mehr erpressen kann wenn
man seine munition komplett verballert
wenn man alle geiseln erschießt oder
alle nackt fotos des ex-partners auch
einmal im netz veröffentlicht denn bei
erpressung geht es immer darum mit
seinem opfer zu spielen ist ein
konstanter angst vor dem eintritt der
drohungen zu halten ohne sie jedoch
jemals alle wahr zu machen eine profi
erpresser ist vor allem ein profi des
dramas der verunsicherung der
unberechenbarkeit und stetigkeit und des
ewigen hin und her mal muss er sich als
böse und maliziös und dann wieder als
kooperieren und gütig zeigen ein
balance-akt ohren sein kopf ein
dauernder ambivalenz zu halten mit vor
allem er wird seine ultimative drohung
knie war machen denn dann würde auch er
alles verlieren
und ihr werdet ihr es vielleicht sagen
gut dann brauchen wir also keine echte
angst zu haben richtig putin wird das
gas nicht abdrehen problem gelöst lasst
uns zur tagesordnung übergehen nun nein
ganz und gar nicht schaut euch mal diese
grafik
was ihr hier seht ist der preis der
erdgas ttf futures er ist im grunde die
referenz für gas preisverhandlungen
jedes land kaufte gas zu
unterschiedlichen preisen ein aber ist
orientiert sich dabei an den flug zu
erwarten entwicklung der preise eben der
futures deswegen können wir auf jeden
fall sagen dass der gaspreis überall in
die höhe geschossen ist tatsächlich
können wir daraus zwei schlüsse ziehen
erstens ist russland mehr denn je daran
interessiert dass weiterhin zu
überhöhten preisen zu verkaufen 22 so
hohen gewinnspannen könnte russland die
gasmenge dieses verkauft reduzieren und
immer noch eine ganze schule gewinn
machen und genau das ist es was putin
tut denn auf diese weise schlägt er zwei
fliegen mit einer klappe zum einen
verdient dutzende von milliarden ohne
mehr gas liefern zu müssen sondern sogar
weniger finanziert damit an seinem
trikot zum anderen bringt europa an den
rand der verzweiflung einfach genial
nicht wahr die frage lautet also nicht
auch putin den gashahn ganz zudrehen
wird sein um wie viel er die lieferungen
wann reduzieren wird 20% 50% 80 prozent
nun kann ja niemand in die zukunft
blicken aber man könnte eine schätzung
abgeben natürlich eine qualifizierte
nicht einfach so aus der hüfte heraus
also wie könnte man das am besten
anstellen
nur könnten nur zum beispiel berechnen
wie viel geld der kreml braucht uns ein
haushalt in diesem jahr auszugleichen
von dort aus gehen könnten wir den preis
der gas termingeschäfte als maßstab
nehmen je teurer das gas wird desto mehr
wird russland angebot reduzieren können
allerdings benötigt europa im sommer
eben wesentlich weniger gas als im
winter das spielt das also schon seit
diesem frühjahr gespielt wird heißt
kampf um den gaspreis und zwar den im
winter deswegen hat die eu nun ihre
gasspeicher im blitztempo nach dem motto
whatever it takes gefüllt es war egal
dass sie dabei jetzt den gaspreis um
exorbitante höhen trieb in einem sommer
spielt dies keine so große rolle
russland kannst du diesen hohen preisen
weniger gas verkaufen als im winter denn
erst mit dem anbrechen der heizsaison
auf der nordhalbkugel wird so richtig
interessant russland oder versuchen den
preis weiter hochzuhalten und europa
wird versuchen ihn zu drücken wie dies
ablaufen wird nur die europäer werden
den markt mit hilfe ihrer aral gefüllten
gasspeicher und durch preis deckelung
der russischen lieferungen zu
stabilisieren versuchen und gazprom wird
ihn übliche masche abziehen die schon
die ganze zeit nutzt formal als
vertragskonform aussehen aber jeden
erdenklichen bullshit vorgang nutzen um
die lieferungen zu limitieren und sei
dieser noch so durchschaubar denn
gazprom geht es wie gesagt darum sein
opfer europa maximal zappeln zu lassen
weswegen sie den gashahn mal aufdrehen
einundzwanzigste juni 2022 russisches
gas fließt wieder über die nord stream
pipeline nach europa und nur kurz darauf
wieder komplett abdrehen und
gleichzeitig woanders aufdrehen dritter
september 2022 der russische
energieriese erklärte am freitag dass an
den nord stream pipeline nach
deutschland nicht wie geplant wieder in
betrieb nehmen wird das komplette
stattdessen nach dem nord stream stopp
angeblich mehr gas über die ukraine in
die eu liefern wie ihr seht sprechen wir
über ein knallhartes pokerspiel dass wir
beide gegenspieler europa und russland
eine recht komplizierte situation
darstellt welche karten halten sie also
konkret in der hand wie sehr die harten
zahlen hierzu aus und auf welche
szenarien müssen wir uns gefasst machen
nun das werden wir uns jetzt sofort
sehen
[Musik]
vorräte für den strengen winter anlegen
bevor wir weiter machen lasst mich ein
paar zahlen nennen um euch das ausmaß
des problems zu verdeutlichen im jahr
2020 importierte die europäische union
knapp 400 milliarden kubikmeter gas von
dieser menge kann man 2020 174
milliarden kubikmeter aus russland im
jahr 2021 waren es etwas weniger und 150
milliarden kubikmeter die frage ist nun
wie kann europa diese 150 bis 170
milliarden kubikmeter gas ersetzen
könnten sie von anderen lieferanten
kommen reichen die gasspeicher aus 0
sowohl die internationale energieagentur
als auch die europäische kommission
haben einen plan und der erste teil
dieses plans ist bereits so gut wie
umgesetzt die gastanks führt diesen
winter bis zum anschlag zu füllen alle
länder lägen nämlich auch normalerweise
im sommer gasreserven an um
nachfragespitzen während der
wintermonate abzudecken aber auch falls
es eben zu lieferausfällen kommen sollte
zum zeitpunkt der erstellung dieses
videos hatte es die eu geschafft ihre
speicher bereits auf einen stand von 82%
das entspricht 91 milliarden kubikmetern
gas zu füllen das ziel sind schließlich
95 prozent was etwa 105 milliarden
kubikmetern entspricht aus dieser zahl
haben sie übrigens die speicher der
ukraine und großbritanniens
ausgeklammert obwohl diese eigentlich
auch im europäischen gas verbot
einspringen können ihre reserven
belaufen sich auf etwa weitere zehn
milliarden kubikmeter fakt ist also dass
es gemäß dieser ganzen zahlen danach
aussieht als könnten rund 74 prozent der
russischen gaslieferungen ein ganzes
jahr allein aus den speichern entnommen
werden falls putin also wirklich sein
ganzes jahr den hahn komplett zu drehen
würde das ist allerdings gar nicht
notwendig da hauptsächlich die kalten
monate november bis februar eine
kritische rolle spielen in diesen vier
monaten wird etwa die hälfte des gases
also 200 milliarden kubikmeter
verbraucht wobei etwa 80 milliarden
kubikmeter davon reden früher aus
russland kamen und diese könnten nun auf
jeden fall allein aus den gebildeten
whatever it takes reserven ersetzt
werden allerdings dürfen dann bloß keine
weiteren lieferanten ausfallen denn
diese reservoirs reichen wie gesagt noch
nicht einmal aus um die hälfte des
kompletten eu hinter bedarf zu decken
und das bedeutet vor allem dass die
rolle denn nicht russischen gas quellen
umso größer wird genauso wie die der
maßnahmen zur senkung des verbrauchs vor
allem des überflüssigen verbrauchs
[Musik]
laut der internationalen energieagentur
könnten die europäer zehn bis zwölf
milliarden kubikmeter gas einsparen wenn
sie sich einig wären und den thermostat
in diesem winter um ein grad senken
würden das wäre eine gute idee aber es
ist nicht genug schließlich stellen die
gasreserven die stärkste waffe der eu im
gaspreis krieg mit russland da und wenn
die europäer diese im winter komplett
verheizen stehen sie im frühjahr mit
leeren händen das heißt speichern da und
das ganze spiel könnte von vorn beginnen
also muss noch viel mehr eingespart
werden denn nur so lassen sich die
märkte dauerhaft beruhigen und die
preise senken als die eu-kommission zb
ende august verkündete man hätte die
speicher viel früher als gedacht auch 80
prozent gefüllt halbierte sich fast der
preis für erdgas futures und wenn den
marktteilnehmern weitere beweise
präsentiert werden dass europa keine
engpässe und not einkäufe im winter
drohen und ist im nächsten jahr auch
keine whatever it takes aktion ergeben
muss werden sie sich gegenseitig über
den haufen rennen um all ihre
überteuerten long kontrakte loszuwerden
das wird dann wie das berühmte
glücksritter finale aussehen die
europäer werden hollywood mäßig grinsen
wie eddie murphy und dan aykroyd und
putin und medwedew dumm aus der wäsche
gucken die in die alten rassistischen
jim rogers um einen solchen sieg im
energie krieg zu erringen ist jedoch
noch ein weiterer schritt nötig die
sicherung alternativen gaslieferanten
also schauen wir doch mal welche anderen
länder gas nach europa verkaufen
[Musik]
wie ihr sehen könnt tauchen hier nicht
allzu viele namen auf und vergesst nicht
dass das meiste gas über pipelines nach
europa kommt eine pipeline kann man
jedoch nicht über nacht bauen end noch
wegen laufen die pumpen bereits auf
hochtouren ihre pipelines können nicht
mehr gas liefern ein weiterer lieferant
ist algerien in den letzten monaten hat
die italienische eni einen vertrag mit
der algerischen im südtrakt ausgehandelt
um an weitere vier milliarden kubikmeter
gas zu kommen das ist gut aber es ist
nicht genug und wird auch nicht
rechtzeitig ankommen von der leyen ist
nach aserbaidschan gereist um über
weitere gas käufer zu verhandeln aber
wieder einmal werden sie nicht vor dem
winter ein treffen der bau von pipelines
kann die jahre dauern viele jahre mit
anderen worten all diese maßnahmen sind
langfristiger natur werden jedoch keine
auswirkungen auf diesen winter haben
welche alternativen gibt es dann aber
noch nun um die kümmern wir uns jetzt
also aufgepasst
whatever it takes egal zu welchem preis
stell dir eine methan trecker vor das
ist ein riesiges schiff das
verflüssigtes erdgas transportiert es
ist dabei die küste von pakistan zu
erreichen vom hafen aus kannst du ist
bereits am horizont herannahen sehen
aber nur ein paar meilen vor seiner
ankunft in zielhafen dreht der tanker um
warum was der kapitän in letzter minute
einen anruf erhielt verkaufte das gas
nach europa sie werden wir viel er dafür
zahlen als die pakistanis die situation
die ich gerade beschrieben habe ist ganz
real das ist wirklich passiert und zwar
nicht nur einmal sondern mehrmals in
diesem jahr der gasmarkt ist zu einem
echten türkischen basar geworden zieht
es mal so es gibt zwei möglichkeiten
sich etwas zu besorgen die eine ist über
eine pipeline die andere ist das schiff
in diesem fall handelt es sich um
verflüssigtes erdgas das gas das über
die pipeline kommt wird im rahmen großer
verträge ausgehandelt und es sind immer
auch politiker beteiligt zb war mario
draghi selbst als ministerpräsident von
italien war bei der unterzeichnung des
vertrags zwischen eni und sonatrach
anwesend normalerweise geht es bei
diesem abkommen und gigantische
geldbeträge uns sehr lange laufzeiten
einige können sich über mehr als zehn
jahre erstrecken der vorteil des
einkaufs auf diesem wege ist dass die
preise sehr niedrig sind
ln sie kann bis zu drei mal so teuer
sein wie pipelinegas da sich europa also
in der vergangenheit bereits billiges
gas oder pipelines gesichert hatte
kaufte es kaum lng aber jetzt braucht
europa dieses gas dringend und es hat
verdammt viel mehr geld als andere
länder wie zum beispiel pakistan
wir befinden uns also in einem
preiskrieg in diesem fall geht es nicht
nur um große kontrakte die zwischen
politikern abgeschlossen werden sondern
alle akten von unabhängigen gas händlern
werden ebenfalls mit einbezogen um mit
ihrer gasspeicher zu füllen lautet die
devise der eu eben whatever it takes was
immer auch die anderen zu zahlen bereit
sind wir europäer werden sie überbieten
bis 2022 wird zum beispiel belgien seine
eltern die einkäufe schätzungsweise um
650 prozent erhöhen in der zwischenzeit
in pakistan zukäufe um 72 prozent
gesunken anders formuliert europa kauft
einen großen teil des gases das nach
asien gehen würde aber woher kommt
dieses nach flüssigerdgas konkret nun
hauptsächlich aus den vereinigten
staaten aber europa kauft momentan gas
aus allen möglichen ländern katar
natürlich ägypten nigeria und so weiter
und so fort
interessanterweise sind ist gar nicht
mal so sehr die förder und terminal
kapazitäten in diesen herkunftsländern
wie den flaschenhals bei diesem wettlauf
darstellen sondern die verfügbarkeit von
schiffen wie sich nämlich herausgestellt
hat haben die reedereien nicht einfach
die ganze zeit 50 prozent frei kapazität
an allen ecken herum stehen sie dann mal
auf die schnelle loszuschicken nur weil
die europäer gerade plötzlich ihre
speicher füllen müssen deswegen müssen
sich die pakistanis und viele andere
eben ein wenig gedulden bis die weltweit
verfügbaren schiffe wieder auch sie
beliefern können was eben der fall sein
wird wenn die eu reserve aufgefüllt sind
da diese ja aber auch strategischen
gründen im winter nicht komplett
aufgebraucht werden sollen ist die frage
allerdings auch inwieweit die schiffs
kapazitäten ausreichen werden um die
ganzen 160 milliarden kubikmeter
russischen gases durch energie zu
ersetzen nun ehrlich gesagt ist das
ziemlich kompliziert derzeit geschätzt
dass europa laufend zusätzlich 50
milliarden kubikmeter lng von anderen
anbietern kaufen könnte
[Musik]
also rechnen wir doch mal nach wir haben
etwa zehn milliarden kubikmeter gespart
indem wir den thermostat gesenkt haben
sagen wir mal dass man durch erweiterte
sparmaßnahmen nochmals weitere zehn
milliarden kubikmeter herausquetschen
dem zum beispiel in büros der
ministerien und thalamus abgeordneten
nur noch mit eigener heißer luft geheizt
wird wird ja im überfluss generiert auch
im winter aber spaß beiseite mit den 50
milliarden kubikmetern zusätzlichen
energie haben sich bereits 70 milliarden
kubikmeter
150 - 70 macht immer noch 80 milliarden
kubikmeter defizit mit anderen worten
wir brauchen immer noch russland wenn
die speicher nicht fast leer laufen
sollen also was kann man noch tun um
russisches gas zu ersetzen nun wir
sollten ganz schnell auch andere
energiequellen zu greifen deutschland
will kohlekraftwerke reaktivieren da
russland den gasfluss drosselt
deutschland will den ausstieg aus der
kernenergie wegen der drohenden
energieknappheit im winter überdenken
tja nur kurz bevor ich anfing dieses
video zu drehen kann denn auch die
anmeldung wirtschaftsminister harbeck
habe nach einem zweiten stresstest
entschieden dass die atomkraftwerke isar
2 und neckarwestheim bis mitte april
2023 strom produzieren sollen an der
geplanten stilllegung des kernkraftwerks
emsland hielt dem minister erst mal fest
schließlich finden im oktober den
niedersächsischen landtagswahl statt nur
die grüne basis kocht schon jetzt
versucht mal sehen so was ich habe aber
danach durch regt nun ja immerhin
bleiben zwei von drei kraftwerken etwas
länger am netz das ist ein guter erster
weil absolut notwendiger schritt mehr
nicht denn wenn wir uns die konkreten
zahlen ansehen wie allein und
verantwortungsbereich der deutschen
politik liegen wird klar die deutschen
atom und kohle ausstiege haben selbst im
gesamteuropäischen maßstab gewaltige
auswirkungen sie sind also schon
deswegen revisionsbedürftig da sie für
ganz europa ein erhebliches und
politisches risiko geschaffen haben dass
die energiesicherheit des kontinents auf
unverantwortliche weise aufs spiel setzt
alleine ideologisch bedingte deutsche
atomausstieg seit 2011 bedeutet einen
verlust von 180 terawattstunden energie
menge pro jahr umgerechnet sind das also
18 milliarden kubikmeter gas im rahmen
des kohle ausstiegs wurden von 2000 bis
2029 die jahreskapazität
96 terawattstunden reduziert und bis
2025 sollen weitere 61 terawattstunden
abgebaut werden um gerechte sprechen wir
also von weiteren rund 16 milliarden
kubikmetern erdgas mit anderen worten
allein aufgrund der als energiewende
durch die deutschen regierungen
betriebenen deindustrialisierung politik
entsteht auf dem europäischen
energiemarkt eine lücke die bis zu 34
milliarden kubikmeter gas entspricht ja
ja das wäre übrigens heute 42 prozent
der russischen gasimporte nach
deutschland und etwa 60 prozent der
transportkapazität von nord stream nun
ist es aber leider so dass ein großteil
dieses abbaus schon angerichtet wurde
warum es jetzt nur noch geht ist sehr
sehr teure schadensbegrenzung und eine
laufzeit erweiterung bis zum anschlag
womit für den kommenden winter drei
verschiedene szenarien vor uns liegen
[Musik]
das beste davon der rebellen russland
den hahn nicht zu drastisch zudreht
nehmen wir an sie liefern weiterhin 60
bis 80 prozent des gases dann wäre für
europa alles in butter der in diesem
fall könnten die gasspeicher gefüllt
bleiben und auch die preise würden sich
wieder auf ein erträgliches niveau
beruhigen das mittlere szenario wäre
dass russland das gas noch ein bisschen
mehr abdreht um die preise in die höhe
zu treiben und die frierenden eben
bürger auf die straße dann könnte die eu
kommission jedoch einen teil ihrer
reserven nutzen um das angebotsdefizit
zu kompensieren es wäre ein katz und
maus spiel bei dem die marktmacht putins
in der drosselung der pipeline
kapazitäten liegt wo die marktmacht der
eu in der einleitung ihrer gasreserven
ins netz dabei kommt die vorhin erwähnte
kalkulation des geldbedarfs des kreml
ins spiel die wir uns noch im kommenden
videos ansehen werden inwieweit wird
putin also bereit sein auf geld zu
verzichten und inwieweit wird die eu
bereit sein ihre reserven zu opfern um
in die preise kaputt zu machen falls die
eu die reserven auf kluge weise
einspeist wird sie die gaspreise zu
drücken und glätten können und damit die
nerven ihre bürger falls sie dies jedoch
nicht schafft wird die märkte auf jeden
neuen zug jeder seite mit wilden
preisausschlägen reagieren falls die eu
viele ihrer reserven einsatz es müssten
die gasspeicher im sommer wieder mit
teurem lng aufgefüllt werden industrie
würde darunter leiden die tschechen
würden vielleicht weniger bier trinken
müssen aber sie würden nicht frieren das
wirklich schlimmes szenario wäre wenn
putin wirkliche bonk geht den hahn
komplett zu treten die oben
beschriebenen maßnahmen zur
verbrauchsreduzierung und aktivierung
anderer energiequellen nicht umgesetzt
würden oder gleichzeitig gar
alternativen gaslieferanten ausfall fakt
ist mit der richtig großen offensive in
seinem energie krieg gegen europa wird
bleiben putin höchstwahrscheinlich im
winter losschlagen bei der kontinent am
stärksten der kälte ausgesetzt seien und
es am meisten wehtut wird wobei wir aus
der geschichte gut wissen das ist oft
gerade das wetter war das schon so
manchen größenwahnsinnigen feldherren
das genick gebrochen hat trotzdem falls
zu viele widrige faktoren für europa auf
einmal zusammenkommen könnte die eu in
die situation einer gas rationierung
hineinschlittern die regierungen würden
dabei den haushalten vorrang vor der
industrie geben fabriken wir beschließen
müssen es käme zu massiven einbrüchen
der produktion der lieferketten der
wirtschaftsleistung und folglich ist
wohlstands aller europäer in einigen
ländern europas könnte darüber hinaus
die heizung nur noch zu bestimmten
tageszeiten angestellt werden und auch
putin würde keinen cent verdienen also
was denkt ihr in welchem dieser drei
szenarien werden der landen wie heiß
wird dieser winter wirklich werden
werden wir die stärkeren nerven behalten
putin oder die eu wird es möglich sein
wollen dem nächsten winter die oben
beschriebenen maßnahmen umzusetzen und
vielleicht auch neue gas lieferanten zu
finden und wie bereitet ihr euch auf den
winter vor wie immer sind wir auf eure
angeregte diskussion zu diesen
kontroversen thema schon mächtig
gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat und hier vielleicht etwas
gelernt habe fast jahr geht uns bitte
einen live chat mit freunden vergesst
nicht dass awo mit glück schon keines
unserer videos nicht verpassen denn ja
wir haben noch einige interessante
videos zu diesem thema in petto
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von rich media als
hässliches projekte weiterzuführen den
paypal link dazu findet ihr eine
beschreibung unter dem video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]